luca das räumlich und abonnenten alter
als massen special
das machen andere youtuber so
[Musik]
eine millionen abonnenten geknackt habe
eure träume williams das immer wenn sich
eine tür schließt sich irgendwo eine
neue öffnen wenn sich jeder youtuber
wirklich mal so viel mühe weil dein
abonnenten specials gibt da könnte ich
ja eigentlich auch mal was kreatives
jetzt machen aber was du könntest 3
millionen an die wand malen alter das
gut
die
das ist kunst
[Musik]
das ekelhaft alter meine fresse ich kann
so viele fahrer dran sein
ich höre das ist der grund warum ich die
künstler werden können das nur wenige
minuten später schlug
luca war es das jetzt endlich ein
special gemacht ja hängt im schlafzimmer
wieso danke für neue abonnenten die drei
ist gefallen